at the turn of the 20th century
America's social landscape was changing
rapidly urbanization industrialization
and a massive influx of Jewish and
Catholic immigrants from Europe the Klan
began a violent campaign to terrorize
immigrants and exploit fears that
immigrants threatened American values by
the 1920s Klan membership was over four
million during the 1930s and 40s Klan
membership again declined but the Klan
experienced a resurgence during the
civil rights era in the 1950s blacks
began to demand an end to the Jim Crow
laws in the south that legally supported
racial discrimination seeing the civil
rights movement as a threat to white
rule the Klan went on the attack
between 1955 and 1965 Klansmen or Klan
sympathizers carried out over 200
bombings and murdered 40 civil rights
workers brutal images of Klan violence
turned public opinion against the KKK by
the end of the 1960s the FBI was
successfully infiltrating the Klan and
its leaders were being prosecuted it
seemed the Klan had been defeated Klan
membership declined from nearly 40,000
in 1961 to a low of 1500 in 1973 but
over their long history the Ku Klux Klan
has always managed to rebuild
[Music]
[Applause]